plus respecté.
Voici ce qu'a préparé
Azeb Wolde-Giorghis.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le Watergate, l'immeuble
historique en plein coeur
de Washington.
♪ ♪ ♪
Un rappel de ce que
le journalisme d'enquête
a déjà été.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ce quatrième pouvoir
qui faisait trembler les élus.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'était les années glorieuses.
Mais depuis l'arrivée
d'un certain président,
la presse a perdu un peu
de son lustre.
Mark Feldstein est
un journaliste d'enquête
de renom. Il enseigne
aujourd'hui à l'Université
du Maryland.
"Si Watergate était arrivé
aujourd'hui, dit-il,
je ne pense pas que Nixon
aurait démissionné.
L'univers médiatique
est tellement polarisé
que la moitié du pays l'aurait
soutenu, quels que soient
les faits."
Lnanard Downie a directement
été impliqué dans le scandale du
Watergate. Il est l'ancien grand
patron du Washington Post.
"Les voix qui ne veulent
ni entendre la vérité,
ni les faits, dit-il, sont
de plus  p plus fortes."
Fortes aussi sur Internet,
et son lot de nouvelles
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Chacun choisit sa nouvelle,
son information, peu importe
la véracité des propos,
il faut juste qu'elle soit
conforme à notre opinion
"Trop d'Américains acceptent
des mensonges", dit-il.
"Des mensonges tels que
Biden n'a pas vraiment remporté
les élections, qu'il les
a volées, que l'assaut
du Capitole était organisé
par la gauche.
C'est plus facile de s'isoler
dans un amas de mensonges
que ce l'était il y a 50 ans".
"Les ennemis du peuple",
aura martelé pendant quatre ans
Donald Trump, qui aura réussi
à diviser et même ébranler
un pilier même de la démocratie
américaine.
"Nous voyons des candidats
en campagne électoraledidit-il,
qui veulent museler les médias".
Il reste cependant confiant.
"L'avenir est sûr pour le
journalisme, dit-il, à moins
qu'il y ait un régime
autoritae.e."
Et cette possibilité n'est plus
écartée avec le spectre
du retour de Donald Trump.
Malgré deux tentatives
de destitution contre l'ancien
président et malgré l'assaut
du 6ananvier au Capitole,
Trump continue à être populaire
chez les républicains.
Aujourd'hui, le Washington Post
a une équipe qui couvre
spécifiquement la menace
à la démocratie.
En 2017, le quotidien
adopte un nouveau slogan :
"Democracy Dies in Darkness",
la démocratie meurt
dans la noirceur.
"J'enseigne à mes étudiants
d'êtrprpréparés", dit-il.
"Que des gens vont les haïr et
les traiter d'ennemis du peuple.
Ils doivent se rappeler
qu'ils sont là pour informer
le public."
Un cinquantième anniversaire
au goût amer, car aujourd'hui,
ce sont des élus qui veulent
voir s'effondrer ce quatrième
pouvoir qui résiste
tant bien que mal.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis